it almost seems like a very nature of
the question should I is there something
here is not the question to be asking
because it's not driven internally it's
an equity they're looking for external
reward yes and that's where like you
have to look at what is the desire is
the desire the big house and the parties
and everything that you think is the
glamorous part of the job or is the
desire that you are sending your message
to the world and making an impact in a
positive way and I think writers have to
move into that emotionally I think a lot
of times they're on the outside and
they're not ready for the internal
desire to really kick in and I again I
think when life humbles you then the
internal desire awakens and it becomes
more clear and then you're writing
improved like i have seen writers who
have been knocked down again and again
and suddenly it's a certain point that
just turns their world and really help
them own what they're sending out to the
world and is it I I think that's the
greatest thing in the world when you see
that happen and again that's the life
process happening mixed with the
professional process so finding meanings
it didn't work yep rather than the
accolades yet and the perception yep
which could eventually lead to a lot of
probably isolation and loneliness oh
yeah because you have all that button if
it doesn't mean anything and that's the
key to everything I mean the key to
everything is when I look at if the
motivation is
leave a legacy and the legacy is to
empower the next generation in a strong
way through communicating your ups and
downs and your lessons that you've
learned through this life process then
the chances of when you're hitting it
big and everything's there being
fulfilling are much greater so I've seen
both happen I've definitely seen the
executive producer who think like I'm
going to say many executive producers
have been married three times are I mean
married and divorced and like that is
because they're putting so much energy
into the job and not enough into life
and and I remember one executive
producer to I asked a specific question
who had all that I talked about as far
as the overall deal the hit show of the
new marriage life was working and I I
asked the question are you happy and the
answer was happiness is such a loaded
question and it was so clear to me that
the outcome didn't match the
expectations and so there was more work
to be done and I think there's a value
in that like if you use that in your
writing and I think that that happens a
lot I think that there are writers who
hit these massive pinnacles and finds
that that isn't happiness and that's why
I think the internal work is such an
important part of the external outcome
it for the same in music and resorts and
everything right everything in life what
is your purpose
what is your calling are you in
alignment with your internal desire and
the external outcome or are you are you
limited do you think it comes down to
how much personal freedom they feel
whether it's in their creativity so that
someone at that level has probably lost
a lot of personal freedom oh the
schedule in being able to go out yeah if
someone knows well and also in the
writers journey you have to recognize a
majority of writers are not writing on
the show that they want to be writing on
you know a majority of writers are
taking jobs that they need to take to
pay the bill and that's just what it is
but the gift of that is that's moving
you forward to when you can write the
show that you create and produce so that
is the show that you want to be writing
on you know so i think it is keeping the
end goal in mind and always using that
to motivate your path and i use this
expression a lot in our videos but you
know knowing what you don't want is
sometimes more than half the battle yes
and it's information like that's what I
always say like getting fired going back
to that what that tells us is it gives
us information okay I was going down a
path and I thought the actions I was
taking with right actions but something
shifted or changed so now I have to
redefine a new path and really think
about the internal desire versus the
external outcome do they align and am I
taking the right actions to hit the
outcome I want